trying to go defeat Maga candidates and
again swing the pendulum back to the
center and I'll say after two years of
working in that space we lost and we
lost miserably because the Maga wing of
the party really took over not just at
the federal level but all the way down
to the state level and the state parties
but it at the same time if you look at
the data we saw the base itself really
transform and this is why I worry about
the next Trump and someone trying to be
a copycat is because they will have to
cater to the GOP base and it's a GOP
base that's become more reactionary than
it used to be the Maga movement has sort
of grown Beyond Donald Trump's control
and taken over the party and I think the
conditions are right for a savvier
successor to take over that movement and
potentially cause greater damage in
office
[Music]
thank you
it is my pleasure to welcome back to the
podcast the author of the brand new book
blowback a warning to save democracy
from the next Trump you may know him as
the former Anonymous I feel like this is
warning the sequel Miles Taylor welcome
miles
Andrew good to be with you brother uh
good to be back on the program so you
are if someone's watching this on video
you're in uh an airport in the midwest
it seems like one of the smaller ones
um out traveling the country listening
to Americans promoting the book where
are we catching you uh you are finding
me at a tiny little airport in Michigan
right now so if you happen to hear a
flight announcement or uh people
boarding a plane uh that's that's what
you got and you hear a good Midwestern
Accent on those announcements too so you
know I just figure while talking about
this book and the dangers of a second
Trump term I need to go into the
Heartland uh and have conversations with
folks that are persuadable
so most people there's the announcement
right on Cube
there it is so most people know of your
background miles but uh let's give it to
people who may not know you penned the
world famous warning op-ed in New York
Times while you were a trump official uh
you then left the administration came
out as Anonymous braved a lot of uh very
significant threats uh endangers
campaigned openly against Trump in 2020
which was a very courageous act can you
give people a little and now that I'm
saying this some people are like oh yeah
I remember
um that if you're an avid listen to the
podcast and you remember miles coming
out a number of months ago when we
teamed up to form forward but you want
to give people a little bit of your
background in National Security and uh
the rest of it much of which is super
relevant to the book
yeah I mean you know look I I never
wanted to be in politics and you know as
I've said to you before Andrew I
actually hate politics I I'm a public
policy guy and I went into government to
work on National Security after 9 11 and
that took me from the Pentagon to the
Department of Homeland Security to
Capitol Hill uh and then back into the
executive branch as chief of staff at
the Department of Homeland Security and
you know I look I I'm a lifelong
Republican until I left the party and I
think all of us were queer-eyed about
who Donald Trump was but there was a
cohort of people like John Kelly and Jim
Mattis and Rex Tillerson cabinet
secretaries who went into the Trump
Administration who didn't know him but
wanted to try to be guard rails try to
help him govern responsibly because
there was a fear he would be Reckless I
was persuaded to come in as part of that
team and to work for the so-called axis
of adults and for a period of time I was
naive after Urban thinking that yeah we
could keep this guy in check but
day-to-day experience with him whether
it was in the Oval Office or The
Situation Room or on Air Force One
showed me that Not only was he
undisciplined but that he was incredibly
Reckless with decisions involving
American Security and American lives in
that position and so I penned an op-ed
from within the administration
anonymously in the New York Times saying
that the president's own cabinet felt
like he was dangerously unfit for office
and were working to thwart his more
dangerous impulses and then eventually
in 2020 I unmasked myself and went out
to campaign against him you know I'm
glad to say a lot of people joined me uh
you know Jake Tapper at CNN called it
the largest group of ex-officials in
American history to turn against a
president who had appointed them and we
just barely uh defeated him so your book
is filled with herring accounts of your
time in administration of former
president Trump's
disposition behaviors attitude sometimes
ignored calls to action and it did make
one grateful that there were folks there
who frankly would ignore some of the
things that that he wanted to do or say
some people listening to this would say
Okay Trump was a a terrible president in
various ways certainly might not have
the the right character
but we made it through the time
um okay uh and your your book paints a
very very different picture I'd say that
and I joked at the opening that it's
like warning the sequel whereas the
first time was like hey guys this
stuff's really not looking so good from
the inside now I gotta say this book
scared the out of me in terms of
what would happen if he were to win
again it was that the one of the main
purposes of the book yeah right on point
Andrew I mean the goal here was
to try to paint a very very clear-eyed
picture of what a Donald Trump or a Maga
copycat would do if they retook the
White House and again if people don't
want to believe me based on my
experience I went and I spent two years
effectively interviewing scores of
former senior officials from the Trump
Administration people are who are still
his confidants members of the Republican
party in Congress and in the Senate to
try to ask them if he had won a second
term what did he plan to do and what
would he do if he came back again and to
try to tell people this is the reality
we're facing so if for some reason they
still think after those four years of
chaos that it's worth giving him another
shot then American voters need to know
what that shot would look like and as
you know it's not a pretty picture it
really isn't a pretty picture and this
book is
it is indeed uh sort of a warning part
two is the first time around I was
saying don't re-elect this man he's
dangerously unfit for office this time I
want to say here's what would happen
whether it's the Department of Defense
or the Department of Veterans Affairs
here's how they'll take a wrecking ball
to American institutions and peel back
our country's guard rails uh and you
know I heard things that shocked even me
and I thought I'd heard it all so let's
paint a picture because you do a good
job in the book uh so let's say it's
2025 and Donald Trump has prevailed he's
become the president again which by the
way I think is a very legitimate
possibility uh there are folks who say
oh there's no way he can beat Joe Biden
and you and I know that he lost to Joe
Biden Last Time by let's call it I don't
know 80 000 votes in in four swing
States a hundred thousand votes so if
you were to have an economic downturn in
2024 or an ill-timed slip up literally
or figurative or Joe Biden were to have
a health issue or something along those
lines I think there's a reasonable
chance that that Trump just wins
outright in November 2024 uh and human
nature being what it is a lot of people
will talk themselves into the fact that
well okay maybe it won't be so bad uh
and you you make the opposite argument
in this book which is like no it's going
to be terrible and here's exactly why
and you did it with very specific detail
which I found impressive and scary so
help paint a picture for listeners let's
say Trump comes in office 2025 what
comes next well a couple of things
really caught me off guard and how
candid former advisors of trump were and
willing to use their names in this book
on the record I mean a number of former
intelligence officials who I spoke to
warned that they felt like in a second
term the ex-president would use
America's spy community and spy agencies
to exactly revenge against political
Rivals I find this to be incredibly uh
likely because even when I was in the
administration Trump asked white house
chief of staff John Kelly if he could
wiretap the phones of White House staff
because he was worried about them
leaking against him he wanted to
politicize the intelligence community
and in the second term I had a number of
current and former officials warned me
that he would use the fisa powers which
is essentially the tool that allows a
president in extreme circumstances with
judicial approval to listen to civilian
conversations in the United States he
would use those Powers against domestic
political adversaries and that was a
real concern but the the worry about
weaponization of government went even
deeper than that Andrew especially when
it was the justice department that came
up current and former FBI officials and
doj officials uh predicted that he would
form special counsels to prosecute
political Rivals and they anticipate him
fully gutting the Federal Bureau of
Investigation I mean we're talking about
institutions that Americans rely on to
protect them against criminals
terrorists foreign nation states being
hijacked by a White House to exact
revenge and while I was writing this
Andrew you know even I felt like some of
the language was extreme and then Donald
Trump himself came out about two months
ago and basically said the theme of his
re-election effort would be retribution
he said I am your retribution I am your
revenge so this notion of coming back
into office and weaponizing the federal
government uh is something that is a
front and center priority to him and I
heard that again and again across
departments and agencies how he would
weaponize DHS and DOD and the Department
of Education I'll give you one more
example Andrew uh you know the former
Chief of Staff to the Department of
Education Trump's hand-picked person to
be Chief of Staff in the Department of
Education said that if he's re-elected
he'll Implement a policy he really
wanted Implement in the first term which
was to kick all immigrant children out
of public schools what am I saying by
that there's millions of undocumented
people in the United States they have
children in public schools an executive
order was drafted in the first term to
cut off all federal funds to any public
school where there was undocumented
children and to kick them out if they
wanted to get money in fact he called
this the Cockroach that wouldn't die
that's what the chief of staff at
Trump's Department of Education called
it and he said in the second term
they'll do it
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
I've always been a mattress guy because
it was common sense to me you spend up
to eight hours a day sleeping more if
you're lucky and so the right mattress
can make a huge difference what the heck
does it mean for something to be the
right mattress for you you can take the
Helix sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes sent to
your door you know they believe in their
product because they offer a 100 night
trial and a 10 to 15 year warranty to
try out your new mattress I endorse this
mattress because I literally sleep on it
and so do my kids there are a couple
mattresses in the house and this is the
one that they seek out even though it
was made for me it's so good that even
my kids are like hey they feel like it's
made for them but it's not it's a number
one mattress picked by GQ and wired and
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep deep
starts now
[Music]
now that hits close to home there are
about a hundred migrant kids in the
public school that one of my boys
attends uh and so I'm imagining how the
heck you would try and enforce that I
mean there are there are undocumented
children in schools around the the
country so I don't know if it's
practical but I'm sure he might try and
find out another thing you say in the
book is that you would see a
hemorrhaging of people from various
agencies if Trump were to resume power
and then they'd be replaced by some real
crazy people I'm sure sick of fans uh
and one thing that people may underrate
is that when Trump took off is back in
2016 there were some sound excellent
people around a lot of them got weeded
out during his term things got worse and
worse and it there's a sense that Trump
quote unquote learned his lesson in the
sense that the the second time around he
wouldn't even bother hiring those people
from the get but you might also lose
conscientious people too who don't want
to stay
in government if you were to resume
power is that consistent with what you
saw and heard yeah the term that I
thought was most illustrative of this
was sacked and packed is one former
Trump official told me if he retakes
office or a Maga successor they will
first stack as many civil servants as
they can from the government the people
that are supposed to serve between
administrations regardless of what party
the president's in to implement things
like dispersing Social Security checks
and rebuilding roads and Trump views
them as a deep state that doesn't
support him so first they'll Implement
executive orders something called
schedule F to try to sack as many civil
servants as possible from the government
and replace those people with partisan
figures and then the other term pact uh
what they want to do is put as many Maga
loyalists in top positions as possible
now I'll give you an example you noted
Andrew that at the start of the first
Trump Administration there was actually
some very accomplished leaders in the
cabinet people who might actually have
been chosen for a democratic
Administration Jim Mattis for instance
has defense secretary could have easily
been a Democrats defense secretary and
same thing with John Kelly at the
Department of Homeland Security in a
second term or or a principled
republican Administration like if it had
been like a Romney type they might have
been chosen absolutely no question most
of those people ended up in the Trump
administration because the conservative
think tanks in Washington had them on
their lists so groups like The Heritage
Foundation or the American Enterprise
Institute put together lists of
appointees to recommend to the incoming
president this is often how it happens
well those institutions this time around
are largely run and governed by former
Trump lieutenants and Maga loyalists so
the Heritage Foundation right now has
something called I think it's called
transition project 2025 where they are
putting together a list of Maga
loyalists to put into the next
Administration one of the most
influential conservative groups now in
Washington is called afpi America First
policy Institute it is run almost
entirely by senior Trump officials uh
that stuck with the ex-president all the
way until the end so even if you don't
have Trump as the next president even if
you have another Maga candidate 8 at the
top of the GOP ticket these are the list
of people that will be provided to the
incoming Administration to hire into
senior job jobs and I think that's the
concern and what I spoke to people like
John Bolton Trump's former National
Security advisor he predicted it would
be the fifth Raiders the you know the
lowest of the low people who aren't
experts in government and our campaign
aides that would take these jobs uh
another spicier quote is a former leader
at the Pentagon under Trump that it
would be quote the enablers
would be the people that take these
roles and I think Americans regardless
of their political Stripes should be
worried about this we don't want a
federal government that is gutted of
experienced people and stacked with
inexperienced people especially when it
comes to things like emergency response
but that's actually one area Andrew I'm
happy to chat about is there were plans
for a second term to weaponize the
emergency response structures of the
government to punish blue States and
reward red States
yeah that was some of the darkest stuff
in the book uh around emergency response
where where he treated it as favors that
instead of having you know obviously he
respond to a National Emergency
regardless of the uh politics of
wherever he's getting hit uh he also had
that quote about
um hurricane victims just writing it out
maybe because he was annoyed he had to
do anything so I mean we laugh because
it's
um because it's real you lived it and
you know you lived uh
um the aftermath in a way that uh very
very few others have so I opened by
saying look I think it's a very distinct
possibility that Trump just wins
straight out in 2024 do you share that
uh that concern yeah look I'll be honest
it's not the outcome that I want to see
but I think all else being equal if it
was a rematch
today I think he wins the rematch
against the sitting President Joe Biden
because the trajectory in this country
but again don't believe me go look at
the data you know on the eve of Trump's
election in 2016 the betting markets the
odds makers had him at about a nine
percent chance of winning that role
right now the oddsmakers have him at
about a 30 percent chance of being the
next president of the United States
three times the odds he had just before
he actually won the role now they don't
have a crystal ball but what that tells
you is that the public sentiment in this
country is that he has a very credible
pathway I actually think the odds are
probably higher than that and that's
partly because if you look at the other
side of the political equation and I'd
be interested to get your views on this
Andrew uh in 2020 you had a very
motivated Democratic base come out and
support Joe Biden because they feared a
second term of trout we are seen in the
data that the Democratic Base is almost
as unmotivated as they've ever been
about their nominee any time in modern
history is their really really
unmotivated about an octogenarian
running for re-election and that spells
danger here because it gives a trump if
he's the nominee quite a bit of inertia
and you noted Andrew a really important
data point which was the let's call it
40 50 60
000 Republican voters who held their
noses and voted for Democrat for the
first time in their lives in 2020 and
those people in a couple of key swing
states were essential for Joe Biden's
Victory I'm going to tell you right now
the data and the cross tabs and the
polls show that those Republicans have
gone back to the tribe they are very
unlikely to vote for a Democrat again
which really Cuts in Donald Trump and
the Republican party's favor in 2024.
thank you
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you
yeah I was talking to an independent
type business Titan and he said he
agreed with you that if there was a
rematch he thought Trump wins today
there are folks listening to that this
that uh are completely incredulous they
think of course Trump could not defeat
Biden
um but there there are a lot of smart
people that have a different perspective
I'm of the the perspective that it's
going to depend upon uh events in the
run-up to November 2024. there is some
scuttlebutt that maybe Joe gets replaced
at the last second I've been on the
record saying I think Joe running again
is the wrong approach I think Joe should
have just taken a Victory lap and been
like hey guys I did the job I beat Trump
I'm supposed to be a bridge the Next
Generation let's figure out who that is
and then let's get Governor Newsome
Whitmer pritzker Murphy Cooper whoever
else wants to run in on a scrum and then
we have a very active process as opposed
to the everyone clear the way for Joe
Tinker with a calendar and have no
debates I'm with you that that's not a
winning approach it pains me that that
seems to be the Democrats approach so
this concern about Trump just winning
outright I totally share I think it's uh
if not uh likelihood it's uh you know a
very very significant possibility so you
said twice even in this last number of
minutes uh Trump or a Maga type figure
and and this is one of the things that I
talk to people about all the time that
uh I go back and forth well I go back
and forth with them I have my own
perspective so
um even
your book subtitle is a warning to save
democracy from the next Trump there are
people who think that Trump is singular
uh that Trump is Trump we survive 2024
where Trump dies and then we are okay
and it seems like you have a different
take it's a much more significant
phenomenon than that and I'll confess to
Andrew to have having been naive about
this myself is I went into the
administration originally viewing Trump
as an apparition as a phenomenon of
someone of deficient moral character who
once he was gone from office would
essentially be replaced Again by more
rational Republicans and as you well
know uh you and I met while I was in the
middle of the fight after the Trump
Administration trying to get the
Republican party to swing the pendulum
back to the center and I will say we
failed miserably as those of us you know
in fact after the administration ended
me and a friend Evan McMullen who ran
for Senate as an independent in Utah
after the Trump Administration ended we
pulled together about 10 and president
as an independent and the president
that's right Evan and I pulled together
uh about 200 Republicans you know
cabinet secretaries and congressmen and
Senators to have a conversation about
trying to go defeat Maga candidates and
again swing the pendulum back to the
center and I'll say after two years of
working in that space we lost and we
lost miserably because the Maga wing of
the party really took over not just at
the federal level but all the way down
to the state level and the state parties
but it at the same time if you look at
the data we saw the base itself really
transform and this is why I worry about
the next Trump and someone trying to be
a copycat is because they will have to
cater to the GOP base and it's a GOP
base that's become more reactionary than
it used to be what am I talking about
I'll drill into three specific numbers a
majority of Republicans believe the
election was stolen from Donald Trump
they believed the big lie a majority of
Republicans today believe in the core
tenets of Q Anon the Q Anon conspiracy
theory that a cabal of deep State
operatives secretly run the government
and a slight majority of Republicans
believe in the great replacement theory
that secretly Democrats are trying to
infiltrate people of color into the
United States to replace whites now that
was not the case 10 years ago a majority
of the Republican Party didn't hold
those sort of conspiracy theory views
but now that they do anyone who wants to
win that nomination has to cater to that
base and so I worry about even if it's
not Donald Trump that a successor will
carry forward a lot of those policies
and we're already seeing it I'll give
you two examples Andrew of policies that
even Trump himself decided not to pursue
that now his alkaline lights are
pursuing one would be this idea of
bussing and dumping migrants in
Democratic cities so when I was in the
administration we got a phone call from
the president and he wanted us to in his
words send murders rapists and criminals
that had been arrested at the border and
bust them into Democratic cities to
cause chaos and disorder and then to
send other migrants in his political
pawns to overflow Social Services well I
went back to the lawyers obviously doing
that was deemed illegal right it was
illegal to try to use these people as
pawns and to ship them around the
country well since his presidency and he
was talked out of it he ultimately stood
down since his presidency we've seen
people like Ron DeSantis in Florida and
Greg Abbott and Texas actually pick up
that policy and pursue it they've gone
and they've stuck migrants on airplanes
flown them into different cities as
political pawns and continued that a
second policy Trump was talked out of uh
was as I mentioned earlier gutting the
FBI there was this notion that the FBI
should be cleansed of deep State
operatives and they should take a
wrecking ball to the institution Trump
was dissuaded from doing that because he
was told if he did that he would be
impeached yes he fired Jim Comey but he
stopped there uh and now you know what
was originally I think all of us thought
that was a fringe complaint that he
wanted to get rid of people at the FBI
and it was only because they were
investigating him now it's a leading
talking point of the Republican party
and people who are in Republican
leadership in the house and the
candidates on the field is that they
want to go detonate the FBI and replace
the institution so again two examples of
how the Maga movement has sort of grown
Beyond Donald Trump's control and taken
over the party and I think the
conditions are right for a savvier
successor to take over that movement and
potentially cause greater damage in
office you know I get frustrated when
because I meet Republicans all the time
who still hold out hope that the
Republican Party can be swung back
towards rationality and that this Trump
fever will break and I look at them and
I say guys uh you know it's Fantasyland
you know I mean they like like the the
Genies out of the bottle I mean the
bases figured out that that they can
have this thing
um so you have a very deep Network among
Republicans uh how many are in that
Fantasyland camp where they're like look
let's just like hunker down and then
after this
um this hurricane passes then everything
will quote unquote come back to normal
and how many if you had to take a guess
if they get asked about things like did
Trump win or lose the election they say
something like oh you know we can't know
we should look into things even though
they know that he lost like is there a
proportion where you know they're
they're just speaking to the base even
though they know different Andrew I
would say it's probably a majority of
elected Republicans right now I meet
with these people all the time I talk to
them all the time some of them are still
my friends and privately they will still
say the same things they were saying
five years ago down Donald Trump's in
aberration this will blow over we just
need to wait it out and they've been
proven wrong time and time again and the
best data point for that is right now
the man they told us would go away is
the leading candidate for the GOP
nomination at this moment and I think
that's the big concern
foreign
some things we do in public some things
we do in private and we certainly would
like to be able to know that when we're
alone we're actually getting our privacy
online is the same thing your online
privacy is just as important as in the
real world that's why I use expressvpn
when I'm online because I don't want my
internet service provider to know every
website I visit nor do I want them to
sell my data to Big tech companies
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
connection a tunnel between your device
and the internet no one can see it it
works on any device all you have to do
is fire up the expressvpn app click one
button it's as easy as that I recommend
this Fortune 500 companies use
expressvpn for good reason and you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
free by going to expressvpn.com Yang
that's
expressvpn.com Yang for three extra
months free 3. expressvpn.com yang
foreign
so you you mentioned that there are
these thing tanks with rosters and Maga
types are ready to head into government
and take office
um so let's look at the Republican field
for a minute you have Trump who probably
would take advantage of these lists so
one of the things
um that I'd be concerned about is that
essentially whoever even is able to
Elbow Trump aside might think okay the
way I won is by being trumpy so I'm
going to hire
um the the Trump type crew uh I don't I
don't suppose you have any sense as to
who else is thinking in the same way
well I I think it's highly likely in
fact you know one of the comments that
someone gave me in the book was that it
would be a nightmare slate of political
appointees regardless of its uh of
whether it's the next Trump because the
people that are being lined up for these
top jobs have to survive a purity test
and that purity test is did they stand
with the Republican Party When Donald
Trump was at the head of it so certainly
don't expect to see any never Trump
Republicans in the next Republican
Administration but I'd be hard-pressed
uh to to you know predict that we would
see any former Bush Republicans or
moderates uh go in because a lot of
those people don't pass that purity test
that these think tanks which will staff
the next Administration want them to
staff
um and you know what worries me about
this Andrew in particular is because
folks would be coming into these
departments and agencies carrying
forward again some of these thwarted
policies from Trump's first term I mean
one of the ones that caught me really
off guard while I was writing this book
had to do with veterans and I wanted to
make sure that I talked to senior
officials who had run agencies almost
every agency in the Trump Administration
and when I went and talked to people at
the Department of Veterans Affairs I
actually didn't expect to hear a whole
lot I I hadn't interacted with the VA
very much but I wanted to check the box
and some of these people are on the
record in my book Trump's hand-picked
appointees that were writing uh running
the Department of Veterans Affairs under
him and one of the things that I didn't
know about that they wanted to do in the
first term was in their words destroy
the Department of Veterans Affairs and
you might ask why why would Trump want
to destroy the agency that exists to
serve veterans yeah he found out that it
had the second biggest budget in the
federal government the VA is a 250
billion dollar a year organization Trump
wanted to take a wrecking ball with the
organization to move that money to other
political priorities again you may say
that can't possibly true be true why
would Trump want to do that well we know
from quotes from Trump's former Chief of
Staff John Kelly and others that he has
a very negative view towards veterans
because he himself tried to Dodge
service in the military during the
Vietnam war he called Veterans that died
on the battlefield during World War II
and the Normandy invasion quote suckers
and losers for not surviving those
attacks and now we see it manifested in
his plans for the Department of Veterans
Affairs which he wanted to yank out that
social safety net from under veterans
his former deputy secretary again
Trump's own former deputy secretary of
the department said thousands if not
millions of veterans would be thrown out
on the streets if they had carried out
his plans to destroy the VA the only
reason Trump was talked out of this was
not because the officials told him
veterans would die if he did this and
they did There's documentation that
officials at the VA told the White House
veterans will die by the thousands if
you move forward with these plans the
only reason he was talked out of it was
because they said you might lose
re-election because you'll lose the
veterans community if you do this in a
first term and so Trump said okay and
they put pause on these plans plans that
will be implemented by the way if he
wins a second term they want to rip the
VA to shreds to use that money elsewhere
now make no mistake the Department of
Veterans Affairs desperately needs
reform okay veterans Health Care has
been an issue for a long time but taking
a wrecking ball to it and getting rid of
it overnight
would hurt millions of people who've
served our country in uniform that was
one of the things I was told while
writing this book that really disgusted
me I mean absolutely stunning uh and I
put it in the book and again these Trump
appointees who were on the receiving end
of these orders are quoted by name yeah
that is disgusting I mean uh no we we
owe veterans uh a lot uh and certainly
uh need to deliver on our promises as
opposed to trying to take a wrecking
ball to the VA it's terrible your book
your book is all full of all sorts of
very Vivid illustrations of uh both what
you've been through and also what would
recur or even be worse in the second
Trump term uh I I have to say that I
learned a whole heck of a lot so you
must be paying Avid attention to the
primary the Republican field you
probably know some of these guys I
publicly donated to Chris Christie uh a
number of weeks ago because I think he's
the most effective Trump foil I've met
Chris and I think he would be very
formidable on the debate stage will hurt
has been on a podcast I like will I have
I tend to like former CIA officials who
run for office so that includes Evan
that that includes will there is now
word that Trump might not show up for
this first debate because he's up by so
much do you have any thoughts on the
Republican field I I'm in the anyone but
Trump camp and certainly your book
pushes people in that direction uh that
there is this confusion that I admit I
share whether there are people who are
trying to sound trumpy because they
think it's a winning recipe politically
and may or may not believe it
um but certainly we know Trump is who he
is so let's do everything we can to stop
that do you have any thoughts on this
Republican primary in the field you
might know some of these people in a way
that uh others don't yeah well I mean
first I've got to commend you Andrew I
thought it was a such a powerful move to
go publicly donate to a person who was
sane what we all know to be true and
saying it's so powerfully and that's
what Chris Christie's been doing out
there on the campaign Trail has been
really making clear uh who Donald Trump
really is I mean he's like a dog off the
chain uh is what someone just said to me
this morning in the conversation about
it and I think that there are other good
people I was glad you mentioned will
Hurd I mean I worked closely with Will
Hurd for a number of years when he was
in Congress we traveled the world
together as a very honorable public
servant who wants to take the Republican
Party back to a place where it's not so
obsessed with social issues and it's
really focused on ideas again and so
he's a good candidate I think the
problem and you know you and I have
talked about this before is if you have
enough of those people in the field they
split the vote into little pieces and
this is exactly what Trump's Playbook
was in 2016 is he had so many opponents
that were sort of middle of the road
that they divided the road uh the vote
and allowed him to rise off of the more
extreme portion of the base and his
operatives are banking on exactly that
this time what worries me
even more is that a number of the people
who are challenging him have a really
tough time differentiating themselves
from Trump because they worked for
Donald Trump like Mike Pence like Nikki
Haley these are people who cannot
credibly say they want to take the party
in a New Direction because I watched
them time and time again fail to stand
up to Donald Trump and so how can they
possibly say I'm going to be better than
he is if they could never dissuade him
from bad decisions I mean I was in the
room constantly with Mike Pence and
Donald Trump and I never once not one
time during the administration saw Mike
Pence stand up to Donald Trump when
other people like John Kelly or kirstjen
Nielsen or Jim Mattis fought with the
president and tried to tell him things
like you can't shoot innocent migrants
at the border Mike Pence would sit there
silently and so that's what worries me
about these this field is so many of
them are tainted by Trump is that if he
does show up that a debate he's going to
look at them all and say you all loved
me you all praised me and in large part
he will be correct with a few exceptions
so I do think that there are some people
who would be great to emerge to
challenge him I wish I wish Liz chain
would get into the fight I don't know if
she has a shot at actually winning the
nomination but the answer here
unfortunately you know to stop someone
like this to stop a Maga candidate is
going to be coalition campaigning and
it's going to be the Democratic party
needs to in some way shape or form form
a coalition with rational Republicans
right now I think the easiest way to do
that would be for the President Joe
Biden to decide he's going to run a
Unity ticket for re-election that he is
going to pick a vice presidential
candidate oh my God oh my gosh wait wait
wait
you're suggesting that that he that he
pushed Kamala
um aside and then take in a mean who
would be an optimal uh vice presidential
uh unit I will tell you right now you
know the Democrats are going to groan
when they hear me say this but I was
just talking to one of one of Joe
Biden's top White House appointees about
a week ago who was lamenting the fact
that Kamala is on the ticket I mean Joe
Biden's own lieutenants think he should
replace Kamala because she doesn't add
to the ticket look I'm sure she's a
wonderful person but democracy is on the
line right now so if Joe Biden is going
to continue running for president then
at a minimum he needs to declare that
he's going to form a Unity government
that if he wins reelection he'll bring a
bunch of sensible Republicans into his
cabinet and I think he should declare
that someone like a Liz Cheney will be
his vice president I think that's his
best bet to beat a Donald Trump is to
show that he can pull together
progressives and same Republicans and
independents into a ticket and if he
cannot do that then and as you noted
earlier I think there's a really good
chance he gets defeated and my point
here is America cannot afford a second
term of Donald Trump so the Democratic
party needs to be creative about
coalitions and you and I both know that
you know people that we know well at No
Labels are thinking about running a
third party ticket in this election uh
which could further complicate the map
and so if the Democrats are smart right
now they will preempt that attempt to
create a third party Unity ticket by
doing it themselves but I haven't seen
any signs that they're willing to
consider that and that could put us in a
very very unusual and contentious 2024
election cycle
thank you
three quarters of Americans wish they
started investing earlier and over
two-thirds of Jen's ears feel the same
way you know why it's tough It's because
it's tricky it's daunting it's
intimidating you know who's started an
app to solve that are the founders of
Bloom Bloom app is the award-winning
Financial Services app it's made by
young people for young people I've met
the founders they are great guys who
want to make you or the people in your
life who are young and just starting out
financially literate check it out at
bloomapp.com and there's a special offer
for listeners to this podcast 15 in free
stock and one month subscription for
free go to bloomapp.com Yang to sign up
today
bloomapp.com Yang why stay in the dark
in terms of financial literacy let's get
educated people bluemap.com yang
thank you
yeah yeah they're way too
institutionalized on unfortunately aside
from
Liz Cheney the names that came to mind
for me I like Larry Hogan uh he he's
like a straight up the middle moderate
Republican former governor of Maryland
who else comes to mind for you for this
potential Unity ticket well look I think
they actually need to go have
conversations
with people that were considered
previously for cabinet posts inside the
Biden Administration there was chatter
before Biden took off is that he would
he would bring more Republicans into
office and names like Mitt Romney were
thrown out and other people that I think
progressives could get behind if there
was a Unity ticket I love Larry Hogan
for it uh you know I you know there's a
number of people ASA Hutchinson could
probably be persuaded to do it
um but they've got to think creatively
and they've got to think fast but I I
don't have any optimism that that's
going to happen Andrew because as you
know the Democratic party is so
institutional they think they can win
this election by playing the last
Playbook but this isn't your
grandfather's presidential election if
you thought 2016 was bad if you thought
2020 was bad I'm willing to submit that
the 2024 election cycle will be the most
contentious in modern American history
and potentially the most consequential
we hear that every time but what I try
to say here in the book is in a second
term if we let the manga movement retake
the White House it won't be as bad as
you think it will be so so much worse
yeah that was the takeaway as bad as you
think it might be it is going to be so
much worse if it comes to pass I saw Liz
Cheney speak uh 10 days ago or so in
Aspen and uh she told a joke but I think
she was serious she said that
um the way that she can be helpful is
that if she endorses a republican
candidate it will get them out of the
race immediately because the Republican
base will be like oh Liz Cheney likes
this person then we're we're definitely
not going to support that person so it
got a bit of a laugh but I think
that's so that's Elizabeth you start
endorsing the people that she needs to
drop out I'm going to double down on
what you said about
um this being a contentious messy field
so a lot of folks imagine it's going to
be Trump versus Biden and Biden wins but
you just so one by my might not win but
also there is a lot of talk about No
Labels running a Unity ticket some
scuttlebutt I've heard is that Joe
manchin is telling people that he is
running and so if you do have a mansion
plus let's call it Hogan Unity ticket
um it would draw significant energy the
other major thing that people are not
discussing enough in my opinion is that
Cornell West now running as a green
Party candidate uh he got five percent
in one poll I saw and and I think that a
lot of Americans if they showed up then
they saw Joe Biden and Donald Trump and
other or Cornell West like they would
actually choose the other so I think
that five percent could be pretty real
uh if you look at what green candidates
have gotten in the past it's a little
bit lower than that but I I'm going to
submit that I think Cornel West
has more stature than some of the folks
that have run green party ticket before
so people imagine it's a two-way race
and that Joe is going to eke it out
um but it looks like it legitimately
could be more than two it could be three
or four Cornell West is real I mean the
guy's actually running and he's running
in the green party and they're going to
be on about in Most states uh and then
that's even before considering No Labels
yeah and you've got RFK challenging the
president and the Democratic party uh
someone said to me this morning that
they felt like a very a very astute uh
political scientist said to me they felt
like the odds were higher than they've
been in a long time for a brokered
convention both on the Democratic side
and potentially on the Republican side
and so for listeners who don't know what
that means that would mean that even
though someone might have won the
majority of votes in the primary states
that they might not be the nominee at
the convention because delegates would
show up and potentially put someone else
forward and I think there's a very good
chance of that I mean if no labels is
running a Unity ticket that what they
call a Unity ticket with someone like
Joe manchin at the top and Biden's the
nominee and you have someone like
Cornell West who could pull a lot of
votes there's a really good chance on
the Democratic side that there's some
kind of brokered convention to make sure
that these various factions don't split
the vote so many ways that Donald Trump
becomes the next president at the same
time on the Republican side there were
fantasies about this in 2016 that there
might be a brokered convention so he
wouldn't be the nominee and they failed
well now he has so many opponents that
want to go against him I think that
there is a possibility of something like
that happening on the Republican side
probably less so than on the Democratic
side but just the fact that brokered
conventions are being talked about at
this point tells you that folks are
forecasting a very unusual a very
contentious presidential cycle and part
of the thing that is amplifying that
Andrew is the focus on culture War
issues and there was a quote that
someone gave me in this book
that I think really summed it up which
is that if a Maga candidate ends up
being the GOP nominee the domestic
policy priorities will be guns gays and
girls and I asked the person well what
do you mean by that and they said the
the agenda will be strip all gun control
legislation in the country an unfettered
Second Amendment to roll back lgbtq
protections and reverse the Supreme
Court's decision on gay marriage I said
well what do you mean by girls what do
you mean girls are going to be the
priority and they said they will try to
federalize the ban on abortion and
there's already as we know almost a
dozen states who've done that since the
Supreme Court decision this is not the
Republican party that I entered 20 years
ago Andrew that I thought was going to
be focused on National Security and the
role of government in society instead
the culture wars are back with a
vengeance and I think that's going to
make it even more contentious because
people voters who report being motivated
by culture War issues tend to see the
other side not as an adversary but as a
political enemy and that's that really
is uh you know not a good recipe for
civility in the in the next electoral
cycle yeah it's hyper polarizing uh so
uh we're gonna end on a personal note
you know you're now going to be out
promoting the book uh your book ends
with some very harrowing stories about
you uh being under armed protection
because of threats by Trump uh and the
like as you're campaigning against him
in in 2020 what is your book tour like
uh you know are you making public
appearances uh and if so like does is
there a concern factor or is it going to
be and by the way I know I mean
obviously like you know uh you don't
necessarily need to show up to
bookstores in this day and age I mean
you can do things digitally
um but are you concerned about
um your own safety well look I mean
we've taken the precautions that we need
to on this uh you know on this book tour
just because in the course of even
announcing the book I mean we received
uh just sort of a waterfall of threats
from Maga people which has kind of
become the norm for us the past few
years and and a lot of people who are in
this space have experienced it I mean
our friend Adam kinzinger Liz Cheney
Denver rigelman these former Republican
members of Congress you know are
constantly talking about the death
threats they're receiving we're on the
receiving end of it too but here's the
thing another friend of mine Alex vinman
uh put it very clearly he said to me you
know what miles intimidation works and
that's how they're going to try to
silence people who are trying to tell
the truth is they're going to try to
intimidate them and keep them from going
out there and speaking publicly so
um you know maybe more so than my family
members would like I've decided to defy
that and just to get out there and go
meet people and have these conversations
and yeah we've taken the security
precautions that are necessary but I
think that's a statement on the larger
environment that we're in I mean Andrew
you and I would never had to you know
have a conversation 10 years ago where
you would have said are you worried
about your safety going on a book tour
it wouldn't have occurred to either of
us that the political environment was so
contentious that it would be dangerous
to go on a book tour but that's the
moment that we're in and I think that's
all the more reason why we need to think
very very seriously about the people
that we're nominating in this
presidential cycle but also about the
long-term democracy reforms that you've
advocated for that can help get us out
of this moment and can help us elect
more sane rational and unifying public
officials uh to office if we don't start
the process of those reforms and it'll
take a generation and we will be having
this conversation again and again in
future Cycles so I think that's really
what we've got to be doing and there's a
call to action at the end of the book
for us to focus across the political
Spectrum on those types of reforms to
make sure that we're putting unifying
public figures in office well credit to
you for the case you're making for
putting yourself out there for your
leadership and for this great new book
blowback a warning to save democracy
from the next Trump if anyone wants uh
an extraordinarily harrowing and Vivid
picture of what the heck we are fighting
to avoid this book is for you stay safe
on the road my friend and uh yeah let's
keep on making this case for Humanity
over this tribalism that's going to tear
us apart if left unchecked well thanks
brother and thank you Andrew for what
you're doing in this space you continue
to be one of the loudest voices on uh
fixing and unfucking our democracy so
thank you I appreciate it my friend
thank you